our Series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us this
morning we're learning about a
surprising safe haven for veterans
living with PTSD nationwide about 17
veterans die by suicide every single day
now some blacksmiths are building new
tools to help chip read takes us to the
shop where they're letting vets forge a
new future in rural Virginia an ancient
trade is being molded into modern
medicine it took us from you know where
we were just scraping and brought us to
where we're living again they're like
angels
those angels are Steve hunts and Dave
Seitz Gulf War veterans who last year
founded Black Horse Forge to help
military families like US Marine Shawn
Mac and his wife Brittany when you come
here it's like a different place on us
like all your troubles and worries and
everything like stay at the driveway and
then you get a little relief relief that
comes from literally hammering things
out you can come here and you can blow
off a little bit of steam you can tell
us what your problems are we're gonna
listen Hots had these blacksmith tools
but no shop sites had a shed on his
horse farm but no tools they put it
together and now teach classes to vets
active service members and first
responders we learn how to transform
something old and start hammering out
into something new they go from railroad
spite prison shank to finish blade while
also transforming themselves I hold
everything in and that might just be the
Marine inside me but like a boulder
they've taught me how to take that bolt
or crack it open it and get some of that
stress out and talk about it here no
topic is too hot after all even tough
guys have a melting point I've get text
sometimes the middle of knives I say hey
can I come to the forge in the middle of
the night people have called they need
to have that outlet they want to talk
about yeah they want to talk about
indirectly were their couch where
there's therapy and that's the real tool
they build together
it's a comfortable place to be I guess
you could call it a safe zone ready a
safe place that's made a life-saving
difference for some who come here when
the guy is able to lift the burden while
he's here and then it he's got to go
home how far down the road does it get
before the burden comes back yeah
gets you emotional even talking about it
you know why is that I think it's
because we're vested we've seen it
mm-hmm
seen it in what they call saves veterans
contemplating suicide who find a reason
to live here about three months ago my
best friend up here tried to kill
himself literally I got to his house and
basically pulled the gun out of his
mouth and they helped him out
dramatically to the extent that they
said if he's hurting financially will
build knives and put him up on eBay sell
the knives and give him a hundred
percent of the money huts and sites fuel
the Forge out of their own pockets and
see it as their way to keep serving we
literally had a bad night one day and
walked here about five o'clock in the
morning knocked on his door and Dave
came right out and just talked to us we
didn't have to fire the forge up that
night they just wanted to talk and find
a way forward with new irons in the fire
for CBS this morning
chip Reid Stafford Virginia wow we're
pretty good knives yeah I mean that's I
love that line even tough guys have a
melting point I mean yeah this is so
great what they're doing it is a
beautiful line you know making things
with your hands is good for body and
mind for them for a lot of credibility